I'm gonna work through two questions
today one from Daniel one from Ravi
might have a bit of breaking between
because they're totally different kinds
of questions the general solution
because a lot of people ask me I'm a
general surgeon this one in particular
is the last question in last year's
whilst is three two paper last question
so of course you would expect it to have
some meat to it okay but as I've been
saying and as you see okay this is a
maximum question when you have a look at
the kind of function it is like it's not
even a trig or exponential or log
function this is a cheetah question it's
a tuna question so I'm not gonna solve
both pass to it this result is what you
have to prove in part one of this
question there's like a piece of I don't
know what it is it's a rectangle of
nondescript substance and then you have
to construct some metal strips across it
blah blah blah anyway um there's I think
there's two strips and you want their
total length and eventually you'll land
on this expression okay which is not
that hard to Marx I don't think it was
that big a deal right yeah okay the real
fun starts when you want to solve for
when you get the shortest yeah shortest
find the dimensions of the rectangle
which will minimize the total length
element okay so many questions now
it's a max-min question so the first
thing that you should your first
instinct is differentiate okay so let's
do it
so do you know Dean X okay
it starts off pretty easy one and then
it drops you right in the deep end right
okay so just sort it screw this up and I
would advise you do this kind of thing
as well right this is a question you
can't you know write it another way
there's not a question but the numerator
is complex enough that if I'm trying to
do this in my head I can imagine myself
like forgetting different chip inside of
that time something okay
so just off on the side here let's just
differentiate the numerator so that when
I go ahead and do chain rule do my vu -
bubble of wah I'll get that arising on
the train so if I want to differentiate
this I'm going to need to use chain rule
in the numerator so I might as well put
it to the power of 1/2 so this is so
this is really what I'm working with
okay so rehearse it with me chain rule
means do the outside then do the inside
or whichever order doesn't matter
because multiplication what it doesn't
matter so 1/2 at the front power reduces
by 1 that's the outside so now go up to
the inside and the derivative of the
inside is just okay by the way I know it
caused some consternation when it was
first introduced maybe let you die or
something
Ilyn what multiplication that's
confusing why not just use across well
because this is why because I've got X
is flying around everywhere okay so you
might like to get in the habit of using
dots of operation
okay so so three we think about it okay
so really that should be read as three
times for the reason why we're used to
thinking okay that's three point four
which I really if I wanted to write it
it should be in the middle is because
putting a dot in the middle if Microsoft
Word is a royal pain so everyone just
puts a period okay but that's absolutely
multiplication okay so multiply this guy
is going to go in the denominator and
that marks gonna term enter two
questions okay so have a look it even
says what I'm differentiating right I'm
differentiating at numerator because
it's messy enough that when I watch in
the quotient rule and I want to have to
keep it all up in my head
okay the more stuff that's up here the
harder it is to make sure you get an
accurate I want to minimize obviously
areas in that matter so this is this
would go on to the heading off exam
technique okay cuz city air is like you
go through all the same steps you just
forget something back sir okay anyway
two X cubed okay happy with that okay
good so this is gonna be if this is
sorry you and B this is my new - if
you're like so I'm gonna pull that out
innocently okay
let's launch into the question rule okay
v u - so if I've got my um X on the
bottom here and I multiply the value -
it's just going to turn it to 2 X to the
that V - - u v - okay what's me - it's
just one so U is just gonna hang out
okay v u - - UV - all over V squared
which is x squared okay there you go so
there's my derivative and I could sort
of start working on it now but any
suggestions what I'd do with this okay
I've thought about two choices okay I
can either put all over x squared or I
could actually turn it into three
different pieces one leave that on its
own since x squared divides really
nicely into this right so I can divide
through and then put this x squared on
here okay now I don't know if it matters
all that much which one you go I went
one particular way I just thinking about
which is the it wouldn't matter in the
end it won't matter again it won't
matter
probably because as well if I put it all
over x squared right then I'm going to
eliminate X equal 0 is a solution but
Mexicans there is not a solution but
it's going to do it so if I'm going to
put everything on top of x squared that
one's gonna turn to an x squared
and rather than draw you know and all
this fractured line I'm going to just
put it as that time